Điều đình chặt về việc dưới mô bộ phận có thể phạm nhân và đạm tính tưởng về mình bài bài tránh lợi giộng của bán em bột hiện tạm.
Đây là nổi giống nhận được nhiều ý kiến của đại biểu cuối khi thật lận về giữa án gật thay ngán hình sự xử dụi.
Hắn định quyền dưới mô bộ phận có thể lưu trữ trứng tinh trùng của phạm nhân là quy định có tiếng nhân văn nhân đào.
Tào các hội để nạn nhân được công nghiến làm những điều có ý cho sã hội.
Tuy nhiên, đề bảo đảm tính khả thí và thận trọn khi án dụng trong thực hiện các bạn biểu đình y bán sận thảo.
Cân sự đổi theo dưới giữa hạn cảm vi hướng mô một cân có thể.
Đây quy định bởi trong khi chúng ta cũng chưa đến giá đây đủ các đồng về chuyến tỉ,
về xa hội, về pháp liy cũng như điều khiến tạm bảo.
Đặc biệt là đến giá về cái tán này.
Mà lâu đau đau đau đau hậm tập kẻ tạo của phạm nhân sau khi ý mô.
Đôi trong việc phạm nhân không đảm bảo thực hiện các nghĩ bố sau khi đảy mụnh tạm.
Nên tôi đi nghĩ chỉ cho pháp phạm nhân hình mô một phật cửa trái con người cho người trực thích của mình.
Theo quy định tạm điều qua dự thảo, không có gá mẹ,
của các anh trị, chào chạm.
Cái em theo như cái điều khiến, hết sức trạch kẻ như là hạm nhân tự nguyên.
Không có gì một tức là nhường.
Có đủ điều khiến xức hả?
Các quy định này cũng cần phía ra pháp thiêm.
Để quy định trạch chế hơn, tạo điều khiến cho phạm nhân và các thơ quan khắc,
tật kẻ quen này cũng như để tránh cái trực làm dụng lợi dụng quyền này trong quá tình tỉ kẻ.
Pế việc giải quyết nguyên vòng hình mô, bầu phần kết thẻ người và lưu dữ tức quyền tổng thì
dự thảo của quy định một điều đó là điều năm biber giải quyết nguyên vòng.
Hình mô và bầu phần kết thẻ người.
Những dự thảo chế có quy định giải quyết nguyên vòng được lưu dữ, trứng bật tức tổng như thế nào.
Để nghệ bán trường thảo nghiệp kữ bộ xuống thêm để cho đầy đủ hợp và chế thật kẻ nớt.
Bầu số đại biểu cũng quát tân đến lỗi dụng tổ chức cho phạm nhân lâu đầu trong vòng ngoài trải ra.
Nhằm giáo dụng cải thảo dân đường tính năng lâu đầu.
Bầu quy định này được tổ chức lâu động.
Có thể nước nó có thể phát sân như bữa đầy,
bệ ăn năng tổng, trong có thể lâu động.
Dùy vậy, nó sẽ phục có thể quy đọng được cái sức mạnh của xa hội.
Tông khiến hắn hình rửa, có người lợi quyền khách.
Sự thăm gia của xa hội, giúp nạn nhăng pham nhân có cơ hội,
được lâu động khu hợp với điều kiến.
Đầu tổ chức khẽ, ăn găm kẻ tạo và chắc thế giới chắc phần nắng sợng.
Đó vào đi vương thế hiệu quá cũng bị tái thông đồng sẽ cao hơn.
Nhờ nó là tổ thức cao với những người đình này và để người chính phố có người đình chỉ tiếp hơn người đình đường tổ tổ.
Này đám báo, tất hiện.
Bung trọng sáng này, cho hiến về dụng thảo lột thí hành tạm giữ tạm dâm và cấm đi khỏi nơi cơ chú.
Các bạn biểu khẳng định, dụng thảo lột đã tiếp cận biến bộ hơn.
Thì quy định của thế các quyền bộ con người bị tạm giữ tạm dâm như được gặp thân nhân được chăm sóc ý tế,
người và nhận thư, sách, báo, đưa qua đầm điều kiện xin hoạt tối thiệu.
Về quy định chách giữa nc cơ quan thấp sáng, bộ số đại biểu chung dàng,
quy định này còn chung chung, chứ quy thệ về quy trình, cơ chế phối hợp.
Rồi nó cần làm gió chức giợ và chỉ độ thông tin giữa con hoàn và ở văn giân thấp sáng,
để chánh đù đầy chánh giợ và nân càng hiểu khoả phản địa hơn cơ xời.
Luyên quan đến việc một sống quy định về tổ chức vụng tạm dâm tại các đồn biên phòng,
nhằm đắt ứng yêu cầu thực tiến trong thí hành tạm giữ tạm dâm,
một số đại biểu đình y cân sự đổi, một sống lột thí hành tạm giữ tạm dâm
và cấm đi khỏi nơi cụ chú theo hướng, tổ chức vụng tạm dâm tại các đồn biên phòng để đắt ứng yêu cầu nghiệp vụ.
Hành sĩ mức thấp nhất đi phạm hạm hạm lộ tối tụt,
đuyên quan đến tổng tạm dữ tạm dâm.
Dạm dùng đại biểu nèo bộ trường bộ công an đường tạm quan trong biết thời gian tổng y sẽ giả sọt,
một số quy định để đắt ứng yêu cầu thực tiến.
Chào nay, cố gọi tích tục thảo lợt ở hội trường về giã nột sự đổi bộ trường bộ trường biểu của lột giã,
giã nột hành không dân dụng Việt Nam sẽ đổi.